[Music]
these are the works of romero brito
they're joyful
simple
and you may start to notice they're all
over the place
but who is romero brito and how did he
become so prolific that he is the most
licensed artist in history
[Music]
let's start with the basics
romero brito is an artist more
specifically a contemporary artist who
blends pop art with cubist-like
abstraction the subject matters that i
do it's very simple very direct i'm very
consistent with my colors
and then the lines the stripes the
little things that i put in my work that
is part of my vocabulary he was born in
brazil to a big family and growing up
was pretty tough my mother had like 12
kids i wanted to get out of the house
because it was chaotic and little did he
know art would become his ticket out
since i was a kid i always liked drawing
but i never knew that i would change my
life
at age 25 he moved to miami where pop
art was flourishing i was like you know
what i love america i love miami
particularly because such a dynamic city
with no formal art training he would
paint on newspapers and on the streets
the only canvases he could afford before
i show my work in galleries i show my
work on the sidewalk of miami he was
able to move into a small studio soon
getting his first brand deal with
absolute vodka and from there his career
took off
disney coca-cola mattel samsung luggage
lamps watches bananas if you can slap a
print on it odds are there's a brito
version of it his sculptures are in
train stations shopping plazas hotels
corporate headquarters the guy has done
the super bowl the world cup and the
olympics
so yeah romero brito is everywhere how
many pieces of art i've done oh my god
listen you know it's pretty hard to keep
track of it
a few thousands
to keep the business going he's hired
dozens of employees and the scale of the
operation is staggering people say that
i'm the most licensed artist in history
so i'm very honored for that because it
means that my work is reaching out
millions of people i just don't want my
art to be enjoyed by the elite of the
world but i want my art to be enjoyed by
the masses as well but nevertheless
romero's art has caught the attention of
celebrities and heads of state all over
the world
[Music]
all those pieces are here are prototypes
and a trillion dollars
[Music]
people tend to say that if you're
colorful and you're fun you're not
serious but i do think we all searching
for happiness and to help others see
this happiness romero's company has
donated to over 250 charities including
the holtz children's hospital in
miami if we see all the time darkness
when there's going to be the moment of
brightness everything about my work is
things that i think is very pleasing to
my eyes and to my heart and make me feel
good because life should be about fun